hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast what are the current advances
in flow cytometry presented by Jay Paul
Robinson PhD in TV or oracle black roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this presentation
is interactive you want to hear from you
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we will
make sure to follow up with you by email
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or even
a button in the lower left I now present
today's speaker Jay Paul Robinson PhD
the svm professor of sight helmick's in
the College of Veterinary Medicine and a
professor of biomedical engineering in
the Welding school of biomedical
engineering at Purdue University I will
now turn the presentation over to dr.
Robinson well thank you Judy and welcome
to all of you to this discussion on
advances in flow cytometry what I want
to do before I get into the details of
the webinar is give a small background
on flow cytometry and I realized that a
lot of you will be probably experts in
the field but there's always some people
who are not and I don't want to go past
those individuals so flow cytometry has
been around for a long time over 50
years and it started out with just one
or two parameters and that's important
for today's discussion because it's now
moved to a large number of parameters
from 10 to 25 parameters might be a
possibility and I think will increase
over the years now most flow cytometry
is going to be around the 5 to 15
parameters and that's the general area
that I'm going to talk about today so
flow cytometry as most of you know
measures single cells it's the most
unique technology for measuring single
cells and the reason is it can evaluate
properties of each population of a mixed
population without physically separating
those cells that's a pretty powerful
capacity for a technology that can look
at single cells in while it does that it
creates a strong basis for statistical
analysis that means that we can actually
quantitate information in each of those
populations that we might be going to
measure now the things that you can
measure are either extracellular
receptors typically you know phenotyping
or you can measure intracellular
components look at DNA or other sub
cellular organelles or molecules
produced in the cell or on the cell so
there's a lot of things that you can do
with this technology now no technology
is perfect there are limitations in
everything and I want to just mention
six limitations because I'll be
discussing most of these during the
webinar with respect to the attune first
of all sensitivity the system has to
have detectives capable of measuring the
number of molecules of the marker that
that you've you've attached a floor
chrome - and so sensitivity above
background becomes important
concentration sample concentration and
flow rate those can be really
complicated issues
in flow cytometry and they will will get
you one day or the other that your
sample is to concentrate it or not
concentrate it enough and that will
cause you some problem and we've all
faced that issue over the years sample
volume what happens if you just simply
don't have very much volume what do you
do and that's an interesting question
because when we talk about flow
cytometry I can guarantee you that we
always say look flow cytometry is
fantastic because you can look at such
small volumes and this is true except
that if you only have a few microliters
of sample then it's not so easy to
actually run it on most flow cytometry
and then the other issue is the number
of samples per hour that you might have
we typically have run tubes over the
years in flow cytometry but today we
move to plates and so we need to look at
issues of what is the potential flow
rate what's the sample rate not just the
flow rate how many samples can you run
per hour not just how many samples can
you run per hour bit how many samples
can you run per hour and get good data
from there number five there is a number
of parameters and colors and I indicated
that you know a lot of instruments are
now coming on market that are in this
range of 5 to 15 parameters which seems
to me to be a pretty popular range and
that's because we've really developed
some good assays where we can get assays
running with a fairly small number of
cells and still be able to look at a
vast number of parameters the last thing
is a tricky issue and that is looking at
size of particles small or large
particles and that's a tough one for a
lot of flow cytometer so looking at very
very small particles
is something that I'm seeing a lot of
flow cytometry doing and so I anticipate
we'll be looking more at that area so
for the next 45 minutes or so I'm going
to discuss my experience with the attune
and the the last several months I've had
the opportunity of playing with the
attune in my lab and I've spent quite a
bit of time with colleagues who have
this instrument and of course my lab
staff who've been using it and I thought
that this would be a good opportunity to
outline some of the features that that I
particularly I find attractive actually
about the attune instrument and I'll
discuss some of the unique advantages of
the technology because there are in
every instrument this there's usually
something that is really quite unique on
that instrument and and there's a couple
of things on the attune that that I'd
like to share with you and I'll try to
expand on some of those issues because I
have discussed this with a number of
people and I've found that some people
don't quite understand exactly how the
technology works so my goal will be to
try to outline that in a fairly easy to
understand way now I like to put this
picture up it's a picture of how Spiro I
think you probably all know him and you
see his book practical flow cytometry
there which I highly recommend if you
haven't got this book and you're
interested in doing any type of flow
cytometry you really owe it to yourself
and your lab to get a copy of this book
and it's a tremendous book I call it the
Bible of flow cytometry but there's one
thing that's quite unique about acoustic
flow cytometry and that is that it's not
mentioned in pouch Shapiro's book
so that brings me to the interesting
discussion now about flow cytometry and
how the attune works because it has this
unique feature of having a different
mechanism for aligning cells and I'm
going to spend a little bit of time
talking about that because it's one of
the most important features I think of
this instrument so this is the attune
it's an analyzer can measure up to 14
colors and to scatter parameters it's an
instrument that has the same general
features of most instruments it has a
sample delivery component it has a
fluidic system it has optics and
electronics and uniquely it has the
acoustic technology so let's discuss the
acoustic technology now I'm not sure
that too many of you will be familiar
with the Journal of the acoustical
Society of America and probably most of
you don't care and will never look at
this journal but I want to show you some
of the things that you missed if you
haven't looked at this journal now if
you are interested in the acoustics of
Italian historical Opera House's you
would have seen a wonderful paper in a
recent journal our issue of this journal
and if that doesn't tickle your fancy
how would you like to be able to measure
the height of a speaker in a room simply
from the acoustics now when you think
about that that's pretty amazing how
high is the speaker standing at a
lectern just from understanding the
acoustic
information well that's the sort of
paper that you might find in the Journal
of acoustic Society of America it's not
the only paper and it turns out that a
few years ago Greg telecheck published a
paper in this same journal and that
paper was entitled ultrasonic particle
concentration in a line driven
cylindrical tube naturally all of you
would have searched out this paper and
reviewed it and read it and would have
fully understood it well perhaps not but
had you been looking for this sort of
technology then you would have learned
about the beginning of acoustic flow
cytometry so let's look a little bit at
the paper that Greg published so here is
a picture of his tube that he made and
on the side here you'll see there's
what's called a line source so what he
did was he said well I understand what
acoustic waves can do what do they do if
I were to put an acoustic device on the
side of a tube and then he put this tube
underneath the microscope and what he
saw were some pictures and we explaining
it to you here by this little animation
you see they put a speaker on the side
of a tube it builds standing waves and
if there were dust in the tube then that
dust would end up being in the center of
the tube and that was like an aha moment
for Greg because he realized that the
dust particles would be retained in the
center cross section of this tube
what that did was gave him an idea and
these are the pictures that he showed in
his paper so on the left here you see
before the acoustic device here was
turned on and on the right you see the
particles pretty much aligned in the
center and so this was the start of an
idea
now you don't transform these ideas into
technologies without looking at the
theory and just in case any of you would
like to double-check
Greg's equations I put them up here I'm
sure you'll agree with me that they look
great and we'll just move on but the
bottom line is that he tested the theory
of this and then built a prototype now
if you go back a few years when he built
this first prototype of the acoustic
system you'll see here it looks well
pretty much like a prototype something
that would probably end up things that I
build in my lab interestingly his first
thoughts on this he brought two people
at Los Alamos and he showed them this
idea and some of the people at Los
Alamos said you know you could do this
in if you could build a flow cytometer
with this and the original idea was
maybe you could do this without having
sheath fluid and that was the original
concept of building a sheath 'less flow
cytometer but as you develop
technologies as I will explain to you in
a moment
things don't always work out the way
that you start here is some more
material published by Greg and I want to
show you what the effect of this
transducer over here is and on this side
there's a cartoon and on here is a real
image this is actually originally a
video but I couldn't show the video
on on this system so I broke up the
video into some small sections so show
you first of all there we have as the
system starts and this is before
acoustic focusing is turned on and now
what we're going to do is turn on the
acoustic focusing so turn it on just a
little bit and you see the cells
starting to move to the center we turn
it on a little bit more and the cells
are further in the center and you can
see over here on this side that they're
really starting to align quite nicely
and now we've got the acoustic system on
full bore and look at this alignment
they're just perfectly aligned and over
here the real image you see that the
cells are in the center of the core and
here of course is the acoustic wave as
they go through the system so from these
early experiments and Greg was able to
show well this really will work on a
flow cytometer and there are some
advantages to this and that's really the
key point of this webinar is to explain
some of the key advantages of acoustic
flow cytometry
now you're all I think familiar with
hydrodynamic dynamics focusing this is
what we do in almost every machine we
have a sheet fluid that goes through
here we have a tube here sample delivery
tube and the cells in here so all over
the place and what we do is we focus
them down through this what Howard
Pierrot calls this neck down region here
and they focus down and we have pretty
much single cells but if you increase
the pressure on this to go faster with
traditional hydrodynamic focusing
you don't end up with a good situation
and we've all seen that in our systems
that you you lose some of the integrity
or the quality of the of the data so
what's the difference in an acoustic
system and I want to make a pretty
important point at this stage the the
current version of the acoustic flow
cytometry in fact the commercial
instrument that was built wasn't exactly
the same as the original concept that
Greg developed he developed a concept
that was basically sheath 'less sounded
like a good idea at the time
but practically it it is not quite as
good as a sheath based system and what
Greg discovered is when you put the two
systems together that is you have both
the hydrodynamic focusing and the
acoustic focusing you get the best of
both worlds now you probably can get
away without hydro-zone exfoli true
because you do this in many of the
commercial instruments that are out
there which don't have this technology
and that's fine when you're going
reasonably slow but the powerful
advantage of the combination of acoustic
focusing and hydrodynamic focusing is
that if you decide to move this system
at high speed then this is where the
real advantages and I'm going to spend
some time talking about that so let me
reiterate a couple of things by showing
you some really old slides these are
slides that have been in my class deck
for over 20 years and I try to explain
with this slide the the concept of
hydrodynamic focusing of the core here
and cells coming down the core
and the fact that you know we have a
laser coming through here somewhere and
is about 90 degrees we measure the
fluorescence signals and this is all
very well but in fact in most analyzers
we don't do this we actually do this we
actually turn the system upside down we
flow up right
the only time we really flowed down is
when we're sorting a little bit
difficult to sort going up because well
it would be rather crazy but for
analysis it's far better to to flow up
so just wanted to refocus us on how this
concept works because this helps us see
the difference between a traditional
instrument which has hydrodynamic
focusing and an instrument that has both
hydrodynamic focusing and this acoustic
module are on the side and so the
advantages here are that by the time the
cells reach the hydrodynamic focusing
area they are already in line and this
allows you to increase the flow rate
significantly without losing integrity
of coefficient of variation which as we
all know is important so when we
summarize a little bit here for what
we've been discussing why why does this
matter I would like to ask my question
myself that question why does it matter
why do I care so the instrument gives
best of both worlds because we know that
hydrodynamic focusing works well in most
instruments that are out there but when
you add acoustic focusing you get a new
dimension you'll see that in a little
while when I show you some some
different data and the highly stable
flow at high speeds is is quite
difficult
to achieve on most instruments but
that's definitely one of the advantages
that we see in the attune so let's move
on and discuss some of the the other
features of the entry because there are
some things that I quite like about the
instrument and that I think makes it a
very attractive instrument let me let me
move to the optics and electronics so if
we take the cover off which I suspect
you're not supposed to do is this is
what you will see on the left there and
let me block out some of this so that
you just focus on some parts of the
instrument there's a lot of stuff here
so we have some preamplifiers you see a
bunch of preamplifiers on on this on
this instrument and the photomultiplier
tubes are in inside there somewhere and
then we have a bunch of dichroic filters
that you can see here and a stack of
bandpass filters so this is the core
optical assembly that you have on the
instrument and you see here there's a
fiber optic coming from somewhere or
other and that is addressing the
detectors from from the detector system
so coming back to that original picture
this is now showing us where the lasers
we have the possibility of multiple
lasers the instruments that I have in my
lab has four lasers but I understand
that you don't have to have four lasers
you can have any you can have three two
or one so the blue laser is generally in
that position the yellow or green laser
is there the red laser is over here and
the
violet laser at least the laser we call
the violet laser it's a 405 sort of
looks a little bit violet is down in the
front of the instrument and if you look
at the path that those lasers follow
it's pretty much like I've outlined here
on this graph and you'll see that the
lasers are actually physically separated
from one another by a physical distance
so that the cell goes through each each
laser successively and there's some
advantages to doing that which I'll
discuss in a moment but let's put for a
second look at these lasers they're
quite interesting first thing that I
noticed when I pulled the lid off the
machine is that the lasers have slightly
different structure to what I was used
to the laser itself is hidden underneath
the instrument at the back but the
delivery comes here into this optical
assembly here and you have this round
system here that is an optical assembly
so what are the lasers they're actually
an OVA so here n't laser which has been
[Music]
designed particularly for this
instrument excuse me
so there are some unique features about
the laser and the first feature is that
it's fiber optic delivered into this big
blob here and question is what is in
that blob so let me clear all these
marks that I've made on here so we can
look at this optical device there's a
number of features the the laser comes
in here
then there's a collimating lens that
focuses the laser and then there's this
thing called the power lens and what
that does as I'll explain in a moment is
it spreads the beam out a little instead
of it being a perfect Gaussian beam it
gives it a little bit of a wider spread
and there's a value in that that's quite
unique in the way that the attune uses
its laser to focus and then there's a
telescope and a doublet lens here I'm
actually going to jump this slide and
come back to it this is what the laser
signal would look like if you were able
to to see this on your machine actually
the specification of the laser is such
that it has to have this format of beam
we call this a top hat or the attune
uses the term flat top there's an
advantage in this because as you know we
often broaden the laser out a little bit
so that when a cell goes through the
laser beam that it gets an equal amount
of intensity we don't like having the
intensity of the laser beam which of
course is the strongest right here but
it falls off exponentially as it goes
down here so there's a huge difference
in intensity at this point if the beam
is shaped this way but that's not the
same problem if you have this top hat
and it doesn't really matter if the cell
comes in at any of these places it's
going to get the same amount of
intensity now you you might not care
about that but in
fact the quality of your data will
change significantly depending on what
you're running if you are misaligned a
little bit now I'm sure you could still
be misaligned on any instrument but the
bottom line is that you have a better
chance of getting better data if you
have this broad bin so for example in
cell cycle analysis which I'll mention
later that's actually critical and you
need to be very very careful and we'll
talk about why the attune I think has
some really nice advantages there now
I'm in talking about the laser and the
laser quality and the signal quality
it's something that people have talked
about for years and years and I think is
now becoming more common in instrument
design that you get the levey-jennings
reports plots for every one of your
detectives and the attune is no
different it has that feature which is
very very important quality control if
you want to review whether or not your
instrument has been performing this is
the way to do it and I strongly
recommend that you take note of those
plots if you have not been doing so
something that's very easy to see on the
ax TuneIn and I strongly recommend it so
why does it matter that we care about
the quality of the laser the quality of
the signal the the reliability of the
alignment etc well that is a great deal
because the goal of most flow cytometry
is to get a good quality cv the best
that we can possibly get and that's what
we should strive at now I know it's hard
to get great TVs in phenotyping but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't strive to get
high
quality Seavey's cell-cycle it's
critical so that's something that you
should take note of and the stability of
the signal intensity certainly makes
important for experiments performed over
days or months you want to compare
results you certainly want to know that
the the data are compatible from one day
to another or comparable which is
probably more accurate way of seeing it
so if you want to be sure that the data
are the best you should strive to
calibrate your system and and make sure
that you keep all of these things
tuned appropriately and that's of course
a scientific goal that I think everybody
has well there's a couple of other
things that I think are definitely worth
discussing on the attune and one of them
is the fluidic system there's a
interesting going back here to another
slide that I had had for many many years
the any modification i've made in this
slide in 20 years i added the the
peristaltic section here because that's
been something that i've noted in the
last several years in terms of delivery
of samples but traditionally there were
two types of systems there was a
positive pressure system and there was a
positive displacement syringe system
these have been around for decades and
you know that in the positive pressure
system the key to stable flow here is
having a an appropriate differential
pressure between the sample pressure
here and the the pressure on the sheet
flow in here and we know that to get
nice sample flow here stable simple flow
non turbulent flow we need to regulate
the pressure here very carefully and we
get this very small differential and
that's how we basically change the
made of flow of cells it's very
different in a positive displacement
system in a syringe system which is what
the attune is it's quite different first
thing that we notice is that there's a
syringe here and there's a sample loop
of some sort and then there's your
sample so the goal here is to pull the
sample out of your sample tube into some
kind of a sample loop and then you
change a valve and then you deliver that
at a constant flow rate and your samples
going through the system now the
advantages of the syringe system as
opposed to a positive pressure system is
that syringe systems are innately
quantitative you can measure the
absolute flow rate and on the absolute
number of cells because you know exactly
the volume you know exactly the length
of time that it's run so that's actually
really important now um I haven't
changed this in many years but this is
really no longer true the attune can go
much much faster than this so that's
actually a significant change in the
attune and something that that I'll
address again in a moment so the concept
of a syringe system allows you to do
absolute counts
so this is just a photograph again taken
the back off the instrument I'm not sure
that you're supposed to do this but
unfortunately when an instrument comes
in my lab or tend to pull it to pieces
to see how it works and it gives me a
very good understanding of how the
instrument actually performs can see the
quality of the construction and how the
whole system is designed how easy it is
to to repair and this is a photograph I
took of the back of the system and
here is the syringe so this is a syringe
and you put the sample into your sample
tube and that's somewhere over there
it sucks into a simple volume and you
might wonder why there's all these parts
of this system but this valve is fairly
complicated valve and that valve is
allows you to pull up sample into a
sample it has to have ways of then
delivering sample of cleaning etc but
this is that the on the side of the
instrument this is the part that
actually delivers the sample to the
instrument and the fluidics environment
is over here now something very
interesting here about this system and I
mentioned earlier that you know the
original idea of of greg's was to build
and design a system that was sheath less
well it didn't turn out quite that way
it isn't sheath less it's actually less
sheath so that shows that this is the
sheath tank and it's really very small
it's it's it's tiny and this suggests
that the instrument is capable of going
for extended periods of time with a very
small amount of sheep so that's a nice
feature about the system and that whole
sheath tank is right here on the front
of the instrument now while I'm looking
at this slide haven't discussed the
automation yet but if you had a plate
reader on the side of the integrator
would be sitting here I've draw your
attention to this this chamber here if
you open that up you'll see that there's
a shift
here so this also is very very small
these are about 2 inches maybe 60
millimeters 50 60 millimeters in in size
of 2 or 3 inches very small and so from
a from a sheath system the instrument
takes very small and just another
reminder of the fact that because you
have this syringe you have volumetric
delivery and absolute count so again we
ask the same question why does it matter
why do I care
well absolute counts will actually save
a lot of money if you don't have an
instrument that does absolute absolute
counts then you'll have to buy expensive
beads and calibrate those beads and so
there's an advantage I think in doing
absolute counts and using a syringe
system the other thing is it's a
tremendously f-- stable flow and you
have a highly controlled sample delivery
and the other advantage i think is that
you can go from from from slow to
extremely fast so let's look at the
actual sample delivery and this has got
some interesting features that that i
noticed on this instrument too that i
found they were quite attractive so this
is the sample tube and the system is
pretty much the same as other
instruments in that you you can stick a
tube on here it's a spring-loaded system
it pops up and the sample collection
tube is in the center of the tube and
does what most systems do it just sucks
the sample up into a loop and you're
good to go i show you this picture for
another reason
and that's because you see a second tube
coming here and this of course is where
your plates are what's interesting about
this system that I know in my lab we run
a lot of plates on the plate reader and
one of the things the staff like to do
is instead of using a well on the plate
to set up the instrument they like to do
it the more traditional ways is take
some sample put it in a tube put the
tube in the Machine and run that tube
set up the voltages get everything right
and then they're happy that they can
then switch over put the plate in and go
the advantage is that hidden underneath
here is a valve and that valve has a
link between this and this and the
system and so by simply pressing a
switch you can switch from here to here
and you can run the system that's
actually a really really nice feature so
well-engineered
system it's a lot of thought gone into
the fact that yeah often the time you'll
use a tube to to calibrate a system and
run a plate on your system so a few
features that I mentioned earlier
reasonably good dimensionality in in
looking at small particles it has the
capacity to use the 405 nanometer laser
for scatter and of course because you
reduce the wavelength of the laser to
405 you increase the resolution so
that's a nice feature but I really want
to focus on this feature here you'll see
you know not bad resolution
here but the real point that I want to
make here is that when you have the
acoustic system that you can run at
really quite high rates even faster than
that but this is a very high rate of
sample flow and get a quite excellent
resolution the other thing is because as
I noted before the beams are separated
you can run a 561 laser on this
instrument and because of that you have
separated beam so you can look at your
fitzy and your PE signal on with
different lasers and so you can avoid
compensation now that's always a handy
feature if if you can do that so I just
wanted to point that out so again why do
all these things that I just discussed
matter why do I care
well I like the mechanism for being able
to switch from tube to plate without
doing anything but pressing a button I
think that's actually quite nice and
also it's very easily accessible it's
open so that putting a tube in there so
the technicians in the lab like that
very much and you can flow moderately
fast without loss of resolution
I might actually change this to very
fast or extremely fast moderately is
probably far too conservative a word
there but it definitely is very very
fast and having onboard
QC etc will will certainly help you so
the couple more features that I'll
mention in in the last few minutes of my
presentation one of these is is
automation already show
the fact that you can put like receipt
of plates in here and and run your
microtiter plates directly into the
system can be permanently hooked up and
in my lab it is permanently hooked up
and we switch frequently from running
tubes in here to running plates in here
so that's the first feature but a
feature that I haven't yet tested but I
have seen it in operation out in Eugene
Oregon at thermo sight is their
automation system so so what they've
done is they've taken their orbiter
system which can sort of grab a bunch of
plates from here and pop them in here
and then put them back and my
understanding that this can be done in
temperature controlled environment and
heated cooled whatever and you can of
course use an incubator and an automated
incubator here so there's a system I
haven't tried or tested but I have seen
it in operation so I understand that
this is the next thing so I'm sure that
there are plenty people out there that
may will be interested in in that as a
feature and I will point out that of
course you can't use the small container
for a sample fluid if you're going to
run vast numbers of plates if you've
really got to have a bigger system so I
put these two pictures they're almost in
comparison of size this is sort of a
relative size and this is a quite a
large container that sits on the floor
and that's required for the high high
number of plates if you are going to run
the fully automated system so that is
there again haven't tested it but I've
seen it operating so why don't why does
this matter well I think if you're in an
environment where you wanted to run a
large number of plates the one thing
that's for sure is that automation is is
is a very good thing running plates I've
found over the last several years that
have been running a lot of
microsatellites
on flow cytometry and preparing a lot of
plates using automated preparation
systems that there is a reduction in
error so robots do exactly what you tell
them to do
they are extremely reliable they don't
get sick they don't charge overtime
they'll work all night if you want them
to and they repeat things with precision
so if you're doing preparation of
microtuner plates and I suppose if you
have one play to prepare then it's
probably not worthwhile but if you have
three four plates to prepare for an
essay it's no question in my mind that
that automation improves the quality of
the data because the volume distribution
is precise the it facilitates timing if
you have to add a timing in your essay
if you're doing phospho essays or
something like that you've got to stop
the reaction at a certain point then
it's got to be precise and you want the
same every time so that that has to be
done and robots very good at doing that
okay so let me now briefly mention cell
cycle analysis and I've got just half a
dozen more slides in in the webinar so
cell cycle analysis is something that
we've been doing in flow cytometry for
literally 40 years it was the tool of
choice in early flow cytometry days you
know there was a day when people didn't
do much else but cell cycle analysis and
one of the things that you know for sure
if you do cell cycle analysis is that
you cannot run simples quickly
is the slowest probably most boring type
of flow cytometry because you've just
got to run things slowly and the reason
is you need good Seavey's if you don't
have good CDs there's no way you're
going to tell the difference between a
very small change in nucleic acid
because that's what you're measuring so
we know that it takes several minutes
per sample it's very time consuming and
therefore it's expensive it's not
expensive for reagents they're not
expensive it's that time the technician
time in the lab time and the flow
cytometry time that will really kill you
if you're going to run cell cycle
analysis well that's just that model
doesn't work with the attune in fact
it's completely changed and and I'm
really quite amazed at this because
because of the artistic focusing it's a
total paradigm shift with the attune and
my suspicion is that people who aren't
doing self cycle analysis simply because
the reasons that I've mentioned will do
it if they have this instrument because
it's almost a pleasure to do cell cycle
outs you can run those samples through
at much higher speed and get high
quality CVS and if you do this on a
plate this is something that I never
thought I would see but if you run an
entire plate of cell cycle well there's
several things that happen first of all
the analysis is a cinch
one of the things that I've learned over
the last several years of running lots
of plates is that software is not well
defined to look at plates why I don't
know because it's a perfect opportunity
you know where everything is
plates are formats are fixed you've got
96 well your 384-well cetera so when we
looked at cell cycle analysis one of my
staff looked at this and just
some software that analyzes self why do
you want to look at self psychoanalysis
like this I'll tell you why this is a
very very simple reason so let's say
you're interested in seeing whether or
not there is a change whoops I've got
the wrong the wrong marker I discovered
that you can actually draw a straight
line if you pick the right one but look
at this you can look to see whether or
not there's a change in your g0 g1 or GG
well now of course you're just looking
at the self but but what you're doing
here is you're saying to you so which
ones should I look at in more detail and
you can choose the ones that you want to
look at in more detail or you can ignore
some of the ones that nothing much
happened so this is one reason the other
reason is sure it's all very well to
look down that way but one of the things
that that my staff member did when we
looked at this was he said well just
click a button and rotate everything so
that they're actually going in this
direction and now you can look at the
rows as well
I'm changes in rows as well as columns
because it never occurred to me when I
look at this
but yeah it's all very well to look down
the column but there are things called
rows as well so that's just one thing
and the achene is able to do cell cycle
analysis in an entire plate again
something that I never thought anyone
would ever do just to show you the
impact of speed and here we have very
well slowed normal speed very fast what
I called really fast and something that
I've whoops I've termed ridiculously
fast I would never believe that anyone
would run cell cycle analysis at this
sort of speed but look at this
absolutely superb
TVs at this rate and can it be done and
can you do really good work well I'm
going to show you something from my
friend and colleague professor Jake
Jacob erga
this is really complicated stuff and
Jake showed some of this data at a
recent meeting and was very generous in
sharing some of his slides with me which
I understand again republished very
shortly in in this book that I've
referenced here but look at the detail
and quality of the work that Jake did
and Jake did all of this all of his self
psychoanalysis on the tune and running
them on on plates and just absolutely
gorgeous work in great detail this tells
me that this is a transformational
moment in in cytometry that that you can
do cell cycle analysis at moderately or
at high speed certainly the sort of
speed that you can you can do your cell
cycle experiments in an entire 96-well
plate and run them automatically and
then have a very rich data set to
analyze this to me
is a transformational thing in cytometry
so why does all this matter and I'm
going to finish up with a summary and in
my next slide why does all this matter
well cell cycle is something that I have
always sort of hated doing it's it and
not just me the technicians in the lab
don't like doing it at all because it's
so slow and everything has to be so
perfect and we've got to be so worried
about blockages and keeping the flow
rate nice and stable but actually that's
not the case with the attune and you can
get excellent CVS and really pumping
those those cells through the achoo and
very fast and and I really am amazed at
that no wouldn't have had thought that
was the case
until I sat down and actually saw the
data so that's why I think it matters
and let me now finish my seminar in and
summarize some of the things that I've
said no I've really tried to in the last
55 minutes just give my personal
impression of the instrument how we use
the answering what I like about it what
I think are important in so the the
artistic focusing feature something that
I heard about and been around for
several years now
and I really had to sit down and think
about and actually have a talk with Greg
can you check just to find out exactly
how did this work and why is it so good
and I'm really convinced that it's a
really excellent piece of technology the
fact that it also is combined with a
sample delivery system it can provide
absolute counts in that you can combine
both of those things with hydrodynamic
focusing means that you get excellent
data that the the laser lines are
delivered with the tophat
that's really finely tuned in a way that
alignment is the less going to affect
your results and if you do phenotyping
you want to do a lot of samples you can
you can look at 14 colors with 4 lasers
and this this separation of the four
beams means you you have less
compensation issues to deal with because
you can set your system up in a way that
that is easier to manage the the ability
to switch from tubes to two plates and
it's a really clever engineering feature
and the other thing that ice didn't
spend any time on this seminar but I'll
mention it briefly now is that you can
run incredibly dilute samples and I I
heard a story of the Greg told me that
Sean had dropped a sample on the floor
and there was almost nothing left in the
sample and Greg said to the the
scientists still have just put some or
put some say
and we'll run the sample and they did
they got great data out of it and the
reason is you can run that volume
through the system in a reasonable time
and by the combination of acoustic and
high dynamics focusing you're going to
get excellent quality data on very few
cells finally you can run cell cycle on
this system at very fast a very fast
rate and get a good reduction in CV and
I've already mentioned the automation
with robotics and that may well be of
interest to a number of people so let me
finally acknowledge the assistance I got
from Joleen Bradford at thermo for her
support for our laboratory which I
gratefully acknowledge for greg cata
check and Michael Ward from thermo who
put up with me for a few days to
literally pull the via tuned to pieces
and let me see the inner workings so
that I can understand how it works and
give me a better understanding of that
instrument I really appreciate that that
support to Cathy rajab whose flow
technician in my lab is running the tune
and and runs our data and Jenny Sturges
valeri per second and Bartok rider who
to support my lab and and and and give
me the assistance that that I have to
produce the data that we publish and
with that I'm going to hand over to Judy
and I thank you for your attention
during this webinar thank you for that
presentation dr. Robinson we want to get
right to your questions and input so
here is a reminder as to how audience
members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left we are unable
to get to your question due to time
constraints Thermo Fisher Scientific
will reach out to you via email and our
first question is why can you do cell
cycle faster on the attune NXT I thought
cell cycle was always running very slow
cell analysis rate I will that's a great
question
thank you I've sort of spent a bit more
time on that
and I see that we're already at 59
minutes here but the bottom line is
because you can align with both
hydrodynamic focusing and acoustics you
can guarantee that those cells are
perfectly in line and that you can go
faster that when you go faster
you don't just broaden the core by
allowing the cells to move away they
can't because they're focused in the
center by by the acoustic system and
that's the real reason why a cell cycle
runs faster something that I hadn't
thought about before and clarified that
the attune NXT has both acoustic
focusing and hydrodynamic focusing and
why are they both needed well as I said
before the original concept that Greg
had was it that you you really didn't
need anything else you didn't need
acoustic fire hydraulics focusing
because you can actually go with a with
a sheath less system but as he found out
when he designed and built the
instrument it works better the bottom
line is that the combination of the two
just works better and when you build
systems and test them and you prototype
them you find out what works better and
that I suspect was developed through
many prototypes and the the bottom line
is that we know that hydrodynamic
focusing works well and if you combine
the two then you get a much better
system thinking wonderful questions
coming in we have time for just one more
why did you say that the attorney NXT
can look at samples with very low cell
counts it seems to me this is a
fundamental problem with most flow
cytometry
yes that is true and you really get
worried if you have very few cells in
the sample and would probably all be in
the situation where we've got very few
cells and but we want to get a sense of
what the measurement is without losing
our
sells and the the problem is that very
difficult
so only attune the reason is that
because you can acoustically focus it
each of the cells that you have you you
can you can force those cells to remain
in that perfectly alignment thing and
you can have them coming one after the
other at long distances and still there
so in other words you have very dilute
sample but you can run that sample at a
high volume rate so so if you ended up
with two mils of sample and you only had
50 cells with most low Satomi's
you would be sitting there for a long
time
you would just not be able to find those
self but with your tune you you can run
at a high volume several hundred micro
micro liters per second and still be
sure that those cells are going to come
through and focus and so that's the
reason that you can you can run at a
high volume of sample and still focus on
those few cells that are there I would
like to once again thank dr. Robinson
for his presentation do you have any
final comments
no I've enjoyed the opportunity to the
presentation I'm sure that if I've gone
a little over time I apologize and I'm
sure questions are come in I'll be more
than happy to answer those either
publicly or privately and my mic may the
links to my website and my YouTube and
Facebook are there so people can find me
track me down well thank you again to
dr. Robinson I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand until November
2017 keep an eye out for an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we
encouraging before that announcement to
your colleagues who have missed today's
live event thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you next time bye